I go in there and I had my file my
paperwork in my hand
that the counselor gave me he goes give
this to the kitchen guy
so I gave it to him and he looks like he
goes Jose Diaz
he goes you go he goes you look like a
baker
because you look Italian
what nationality are you I go I'm Cuban
sir he goes cabano that's good you
people put good seasonings in the food
he goes I want you to be my Baker
because have you ever baked before I go
never he goes so there's instructions
there
your first job is cinnamon muffins
I can't believe that you're in prison on
kidnapping charges and you're about to
make cinnamon muffins
so
so you're one of a kind